[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale avec tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi 3 décembre tout de suite
les titres de ce set 8 journal sa liste
est arrivée en tête de l'élection
municipale partielle
hier didier fischer et le nouveau maire
de coignières il succède à jean-pierre
sevestre un scrutin remporté face à ali
bousselham retour sur cette soirée
électorale et réactions à suivre dans
cette édition
en ce jour de lancement de la coop 24
nous allons parler défense de
l'environnement cette association
sensibilise à la nature et organise
notamment des opérations de ramassage
des déchets dans les yvelines les
marcheurs cueilleurs vont être lancés
officiellement ce dimanche en présence
de yann arthus bertrand nous recevons
deux de ses membres fondateurs et
l'antenne du secours populaire l encours
à la recherche d'une nouvelle à
plantations la haye les locaux actuels
vétustes vont être détruits dans le
cadre du réaménagement de la zone des
quatre arbres aucune solution de
relogement n'a été trouvé à ce jour ce
qui inquiète l'association
elle doit quitter les lieux avant le 31
décembre et puis invité également tout à
l'heure alain degois dit papy nous
présenterons avec lui la soirée 7,8
humour programme demain au prisme à
elancourt cette image pour débuter ce
journal un gilet jaune sur la statue
équestre du roi louis xiv devant le
château de versailles
une cinquantaine de personnes a
manifesté ce samedi dans la cité royale
où le président de la république a ses
habitudes à la résidence de la lanterne
à mobilisation parmi d'autres dans les
yvelines dans le cadre de la nouvelle
journée nationale de mobilisation contre
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat des actions
comme depuis plusieurs semaines sur les
péage de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines sur
l'a10 et de buchelay sur l'a13 ait
d'autres yvelinois ont fait le
déplacement à paris où la manifestation
des gilets jaunes a été marquée par de
nombreux débordements écouter l'un
d'entre eux au micro de marie l'ania
pishin ans qu'on n'a pas de services de
sécurité c'est notre gros souci
actuellement c'était la der de pouvoir
gérer par la suite la sécurité aussi
bien pour les gilets jaunes y compris
même pour les forces de darb parce qu'à
la limite
aujourd'hui ils sont peut-être aussi
dans un état d'énervement qui leur
permet pas de faire la sélection entre
des véritables casseurs
et un mouvement qui à l'origine est tout
à fait pacifique il ya quand même des
points sur lequel bruit on ne cédera pas
et là dessus on est tous d'accord à
savoir 1 le gel total des augmentations
de taxe dite taxe carbone sur le
carburant parce que ça ça impacte
absolument tout le monde
la deuxième chose c'est quand même qui
puisse y avoir des négociations fermes
trancher sur le pouvoir d'achat parce
que derrière nous vous avez toute une
population qui souffre et le premier
ministre edouard philippe doit recevoir
demain une délégation de gilet jaune
c'est gilet jaune appellent d'ores et
déjà à une nouvelle mobilisation ce
samedi
le second tour des élections municipales
partielles de coignières ce dimanche les
habitants étaient appelés à voter pour
les deux candidats encore en lice après
le retrait de david pelletier arrivé en
tête au premier tour c'est didier
fischer ancien conseiller municipal
d'opposition qui est élu maire est les
précisions de mélanie poquet de patrick
jacques de dixmude un pourcentage
pas de surprise pour ce second tour
arrivé en tête la semaine dernière la
liste nouvel élan pour coignières mené
par didier fischer remporte la
municipale partielle avec +2 58% des
voix là la majorité claire
le vote est clair donc je pense que
c'est aussi un gage de sérénité en effet
pour notre commune je suis aujourd'hui
sans étiquette mais j'ai jamais dit que
j'étais un homme
de droite je suis un homme de gauche je
l' ai toujours dit je les ai toujours
dit pendant toute la campagne
un second tour marqué par une meilleure
participation un coin mais rien sur deux
s'est déplacé face à didier fischer ali
bousselham obtient plus de 41% des
suffrages
c'est la première mi temps donc la
première mi temps là perdu mais on n'a
pas forcément perdu le match le match la
deuxième mi-temps séjour 2020 nous
contribuerons à l'apaisement de ce
climat
nous serons dans une opposition la plus
constructive possible dans tous les cas
elle la liste nouvel élan pour
coignières aura 22 sièges sur les 27 que
compte le conseil l'opposition cinq pas
de sièges pour la liste de jean
pelletier qui s'est retiré à l'issue du
premier tour
on fera parti de l'opposition en dehors
du conseil municipal
effectivement la ville a toujours été à
droite et c'est pour ça que je parle d'
assumer l'échec de de la droite puisque
elle était plutôt à 60% à coignières
l'équipe daddy bousselham et d'henri pas
lieu parce que c'était quand même un
binôme fait un score d'un peu plus de 40
seulement et donc il faut qu'ils en
tirent les conséquences
didier fischer et sa liste font aussi
leur rentrée au conseil communautaire de
saint quentin en yvelines avec deux
sièges son président jean michel
fourgous souhaite continuer l'ouverture
proposée à toutes les communes
je pense que d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
qu'on est plus efficace sur un plutôt un
bon climat dont j'espère que bien sûr la
victoire de monsieur fisher à coignières
ne changera pas ce bon état d'esprit
constructif qui lie à saint quentin
je verrai monsieur fisher dans les
semaines qui viennent bien sûr pour les
rencontrer avec l'autre et lui qui va
siéger nick lui le conseil
d'installation de la nouvelle équipe
municipale est prévue ce dimanche 10
décembre à 10 heures à la mairie
notes dans l'actualité le début demain
du procès en appel d'un tueur en série
francis heaulme comparaîtra aux assises
des yvelines il est rejugé pour le
meurtre de deux enfants a commis en 1986
à moitié à montigny lès metz en moselle
est déjà condamné pour 9,9 meurtre
francis heaulme a toujours nié les faits
lors de son dernier procès en moselle
est la cour d'assises l'avait condamné à
la perpétuité avec moi sur ce plateau
deux invités de défenseurs de
l'environnement michael le saunier et
philippe l'isu bon sens messieurs alors
vous êtes respectivement président et
membre fondateur des marcheurs
cueilleurs cette association
sensibiliser à la protection de la
nature et organise notamment des
opérations de ramassage de déchets elle
sera lancée officiellement ce dimanche
en présence de yann arthus-bertrand on
va en parler dans cet entretien
aujourd'hui a été lancée la coop 24 en
pologne à ce sont des pays qui prennent
les décisions qui discute entre le but
de votre association c'est aussi de dire
h à notre échelle chaque citoyen peut
peut agir sur sur la défense de de la
planète chaque geste compte finalement
tout à fait on en est des exemples avec
philippe non à une prise de conscience
en fait qu'à démarrer aux workshops des
tout simplement 15 septembre suite au
départ aussi nicolas hulot on a une
prise de conscience on s'est dit on sait
on associe qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire
ensemble qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire
de manière concrète et quotidienne
surtout
et effectivement maintenant mais là j'ai
une dame qui fait ça régulièrement avec
un sac tout bêtement et qui ramassent
les déchets correspondent à l'extérieur
et elle me dit voilà pourquoi on irait
pas tout si on ferait ça collectivement
mais dans la joie et la bonne humeur
parce qu'aujourd'hui effectivement passé
les déchets c'est pas une activité qui
ont relativement fun on peut pas dire
qu'on s'éclate en le faisant
par contre effectivement on y amène un
petit degré d'humour autour et on
associe les gens dans la joie et la
bonne humeur en faisant des actions
concrètes qui attire de plus en plus de
monde c'est qu'ils ont des déchets
sauvages allait elle est vraiment
problématique tout à fait aller vraiment
très problématique encore hier on était
à st-arnaud effectivement se baladant on
a nettoyé un petit peu on a découvert
une zone qu'on paie tôt sur plusieurs
centaines de mètres où il y avait
énormément de déchets et des vrais
déchets sauvages avec de la robinetterie
qu'est ce qu'on peut trouver et c'est
effectivement c'est un vrai problème et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la nature est
infesté ce genre de déchets il ya
beaucoup d'incivisme beaucoup de choses
donc nous on s'est pris en main on s'est
dit pourquoi pas lancer ça alors là
l'action ramassage des déchets c'est en
quelque chose qui est qu'un point de des
mains en fait nous ont vraiment
travaillé derrière sur la
sensibilisation des plus jeunes des
enfants parce que c'est nos messages et
c'est surtout nos générations futures et
on aimerait beaucoup désensibiliser
évoluer le disais tout à l'heure en off
philippe l'isu il ya aussi le longue de
la protection animale c'est ça qui ce
sera dur c'est un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur et lorsque
d'ailleurs on a rencontré yann arthus
bertrand
j'avais lu son histoire michael est un
fan depuis toujours moi je l' ai
découvert au fur et à mesure il a payé
ses études en étant empire de
montgolfier en gagnant j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer dans mes voyages dans le
monde entier mais également ici vraiment
beaucoup de personnes qui attendent
qu'on soit là aussi concret donc ça avec
plaisir aujourd'hui j'ai encore mis en
ligne j'essaie de mettre une vidéo par
semaine mais c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement bordés donc on a pour projet
aussi une fois qu'on est lancé dimanche
de prendre des contacts notamment avec
nicolas hulot
brigitte bardot et d'autres intervenants
très précis de prendre connaissance des
textes législatifs qui ont évolué il ya
peu de temps pour être vraiment là aussi
concret et sécurisé et sur le nom de
marcheurs cueilleurs ça vient d'où ma
femme en fait on est on est tous des
bases des êtres humains donc des bipèdes
donc on marche tous en fête
sarko nouveau préhistorique par exemple
les premiers hommes se sont nourris de
cueillette et on les appelait les
marcheurs qu'ailleurs voilà donc la
naissance est très lointaine
après de manière plus courte c'est un
collectif qui existait déjà dans le sud
de la france une dizaine d'années est en
fait cette dame donc je vous disais tout
à l'heure qui est dans mon village donc
à bullion petit hommage à vis de bullion
en fait on en a parlé et tout simplement
on a repris cet esprit marcheurs cup
c'est effectivement qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour l'instant tous les dimanches et
même bientôt les samedis et les
dimanches on march é longueuil lancement
officiel de cette association dimanche
mais des opérations ont déjà été menées
qu'est ce qui a été fait ces derniers
mois on a fait quelques opérations on a
même fait dans le 28 donc à epernon
voyez on a fait la plus grosse d'entre
elles étaient à rambouillet on a tiré
vers une centaine de personnes ben bilan
un bilan sur six cette grosse opération
on a quand même ramassé quasiment 200
sacs on a eu plus de 200 personnes
présentes
donc voilà c'est notre objectif à chaque
fois c'est un moment comme je lui dis
convivial et nous derrière on remet par
exemple des petits diplômes aux enfants
pour les féliciter de leur réaction
on va vraiment travailler sur ce
principe là de la sensibilisation des
enfants et pour moi en tout cas c'est
très important
lancement ce dimanche à 10h30 à la salle
des granges du parc opérés en yvelines
en présence de yann arthus bertrand et
philippe kizuki sera qui est votre
parent c'est une chance de l'avant par
envie c'est avec plaisir et c'est
d'ailleurs une très belle anecdote
puisque j'avais essayé de le contacter
et puis donc il d'abord très demandé il
est d'ailleurs reçu aujourd'hui par le
pape en soi au vatican et je lui ai
envoyé un sms en dernier espoir et je
lui dit yann à l'image des sacs de 100
kg quand soulève tous les week-ends
j'incite un peu lourdement mais c'est
vraiment vous qui nous convenait c'est
notre état d'esprit
c'est au jour d'aujourd'hui l'échec de
l'écologie politique mais certainement
pas celle de l'humaniste et du citoyen
que nous sommes puisque si on veut
intervenir en dehors de nos métiers
respectifs c'est pour avoir des
résultats concrets et accessoirement de
découvrir aussi les yvelines parce que
c'est un magnifique territoire et on est
reçu par tous les élus quels qu'ils
soient
bien sûr elle entre nature et urbain en
plus les absolument tout et on essaye de
on essaie de répondre en fait à la
demande
demande d'enfants donc on prend contact
avec leurs parents et ont leur des deals
et ses interventions là parce qu'on veut
vraiment le faire dans cet état d'esprit
qui a toujours été la joie l efficacité
parce qu'on ne peut pas faire les choses
sans un minimum enthousiasme et on en
déborde et c'était difficile de le
convaincre
yann arthus-bertrand de devenir le
parrain des marcheurs que alors je vais
laisser répondre non mais il va vous
expliquer parce que c'est une histoire
fantastique
non non ça n'a pas été bon ça a été un
peu pas forcément évident dès le départ
dans le sens où il est vraiment très
sollicités donc effectivement il a à
moultes projet donc on est un projet
parmi tant d'autres on a eu la chance
d'être reçus directement chez lui
effectivement en un quart d'heure vingt
minutes devant notre enthousiasme et
surtout ce qu'on lui a montré en fait il
a décidé effectivement nous paraît n'est
relativement facilement au final mais
nos pas si difficile que ça mais
maintenant j'ai eu la chance de
l'accompagner aux grandes gueules jeudi
dernier donc sur la lame s'est
effectivement c'est quelqu'un qui
déborde d'énergie et qui veut que le
citoyen se bouge par lui-même il rentre
dans une quête de spiritualité et je
pense que dans cette quête là il se dit
qu'est ce que je peux faire moi même
comment je peux aider les autres et on
s'est rejoint sur cette question là en
fait tous ces dernières pression en
moins de 30 secondes les perspectives
pour l'association de développement
alors donc comme je voulais 10 et
travailler en fait sur la
sensibilisation des enfants de
travailler aussi avec les élus pour
pouvoir trouver des solutions à mettre
en place
d'ailleurs à ce fait ont rejoint
allemand bernhard qui sait qu'il ya un
gros problème de la mer de déchets sens
car sous poissy donc c'est quelqu'un qui
viendra dimanche et qu'on va rencontrer
sur place
voilà on va essayer de faire bouger les
choses bouger les lignes comme on peut
et on va y donner en tout cas tout notre
enthousiasme pour vous et non dévalués
il ya tout le monde mais combien y
trouve toutes les informations sur cette
association soit l'âge fait la page
facebook qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci michael le saunier merci vers
10hoo d'accord avec nos respectivement
président des marcheurs coeur et membre
fondateur de cette association
les jours du secours populaire
d'elancourt sont ils comptés à la fin du
mois l'une des plus importantes antennes
des yvelines doit libérer les locaux
qu'elle occupe en raison du
réaménagement de la zone artisanale des
quatre arbres pour l'instant aucune
solution de relogement
elle a été trouvée pour l'association le
point sur cette situation avec nickel et
demi d'euros et aurait lyons installé
depuis 2010 sur le site et quatre arbres
l'antenne élan courtoise du secours
populaire accompagnent
en 78 familles dans le besoin problème
les locaux de 200 mètres carrés qui
appartiennent à l'agglomération sont
vétustes et doivent être prochainement
démoli pour être rénovés
le bail se termine le 31 décembre 2018
l'association qui a lancé une pétition
en ligne est inquiète aussi bien la
communauté d'agglomération que la ville
n'a pas de deux locaux de substitution à
nous proposer nous encourage à aller
voir dans le parc privé dans le parc
privé
ça coûte quand même très très cher
jusqu'à présent l'association payer 6000
euros de charges annuelles un montant
multiplié par cinq dans le parc privé
l'agglomération et la mairie d'elancourt
se veulent rassurantes dans ce projet de
relocalisation
on continuera de les accompagner on a
même dit que s'il était nécessaire qu'il
soit sur un lieu où le loyer sera
obligatoirement plus cher que sur des
locaux qui sont voués à disparaître donc
avec des baux précaires nous les
accompagnerons financièrement parmi les
pistes évoquées le déménagement du local
dans une autre commune le sujet c'est
pas d'avoir des locaux pour faire la
solidarité au niveau des yvelines où des
habitants de la communauté
d'agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines au sens large c'est vraiment au
profit des élans courtois toujours à la
recherche d'un nouveau local l'antenne
du secours populaire d'elancourt a
demandé un sursis de trois mois
supplémentaires
vd comme celle institut de recherche
spécialisé dans la transition
énergétique il organisait récemment sa
troisième conférence scientifique à
versailles cet événement permet de
rassembler d'échanger sur la mobilité de
demain
les détails de michael mais d'euros et
de nicolas d'andré penser les moyens de
déplacement de demain en plaçant le
citoyen au coeur de la réflexion c'est
l'objectif de la conférence scientifique
de bd comme sur la mobilité et les
véhicules intelligents
une troisième édition orienté sur deux
thématiques le premier autour de la
simulation des nouvelles mobilités
c'est à ces quelque chose de aujourd'hui
de très importants l'introduction de
nouvelles flottes de véhicules autonomes
d'une navette autonome qu'est-ce que ça
va changer dans le quotidien des de
monsieur tout le monde en termes de
nouvelles solutions de mobilité
la deuxième elle elle va concerne à la
concernée le véhicule autonome et son
interaction avec son environnement
le véhicule autonome ce moyen de
transport sans chauffeur l' axe
principal des travaux des 200 chercheurs
de bd comme un travail collaboratif avec
d'autres universitaires et des
partenaires industriels
l'objectif de la journée c'est vraiment
de rassembler la communauté sur la
mobilité durable communauté de bd comme
autour de grands noms de grands speaker
mais aussi d'une jeunesse pleine d'envié
plein de recherche de faire bouger des
choses et on va mixer tout au long de la
journée des experts internationaux et
nos meilleurs chercheurs au sein des
écoles
prochain rendez vous pour m'aider comme
l'inauguration du nouveau bâtiment à
satory le mobile app prévu le 7 février
2019 c'est le festival du film
documentaire organisé par tv 78 le
rideau de la quatrième édition de saint
quentin s'est refermée hier cérémonie de
clôture au ciné cette à elancourt est
les différentes récompenses de
l'événement dédié cette année à l'espace
ont été remises le prix tv 78 va à
l'odyssée interstellaire de vincent
amouroux et alex baril le prix des
cinémas à virgile novarina nx had repart
lui avec deux prix celui du public et de
3e pour l' aventure aéronautique des
bleus est le documentaire suit le hop le
tour des futurs grands pilotes français
on écoute sa réaction est le bilan de ce
festival saint quentin au micro d'yves
cube stand hergé je suis très content et
très étonné à vrai dire je m'y attendais
pas trop quand j'ai vu des autres films
qui étaient en compétition et c'est très
particulier d'avoir le prix du public
parce que sur les autres films que j'ai
fait en général c'était soit poulain
soit ou l'autre donc le public était
très partagé un grand succès le public a
été présent rendez vous aussi bien pour
la soirée de lancement la soirée
bogdanov que l'ensemble des plus de 50
événements qui ont été programmés dans
le cadre du festival beaucoup de
fréquentation je pense que le thème de
l'espace y est également pour beaucoup
parce que c'est un thème
trans-générationnel c'est un thème qui
donne lieu à des documentaires
magnifique
que ce soit en images que ce soit en
sont et qui en plus projette l'homme
vers son futur tout en regardant d'où il
vient donc un thème vraiment passionnant
un événement à retrouver en diffusion
prochainement sur tv 78 le prisme
d'elancourt accueille sa première soirée
7,8 humour c'est demain mardi à partir à
partir de 20h30 c'est sous la direction
artistique de julie chaises et de vous
alain degois bonsoir bonsoir alors
comédien metteur en scène on vous
connaît sous le surnom de papier sellal
a atteint les jantes 18 peut pas faire
autrement que m'a appelé pep voilà bah
on va vous appeler papilles tout au long
de cet entretien
alors comme ça sur scène c'est un show
unique il y aura des humoristes reconnu
mais surtout des jeunes talents quel est
le principe ça c'est le principe d'un
plateau en fait c'est cette ouverture
qu'a voulu laurent mazauric on a vu
juste avant et virginie marson la
directrice du prisme c'est de créer un
plateau d'humour mais aussi et ne pas
faire venir que des des gens vu qui sont
mes de donner la possibilité à des
jeunes de pouvoir aussi excellé et de
veut dire sur un plateau et de venir
nous donner à voir nous nous faire
entendre leur humour leur talent et leur
leur univers en fait donc c'est un
plateau il va y avoir quelques tête
d'affiche et entre entre eux des jeunes
vont venir aussi ou des moins jeunes
c'est pas on n'est pas c'est pas une
histoire d'âge des jeunes dans l'humour
qui vont venir effectivement présenté un
sketch dix minutes quand autour de ça
voilà alors sur ce territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines vous avez connu
nombreuses aventures celle de la
fondation l'aco fondation de déclic
théâtre dans les années 90 là pourquoi
se lancer dans cette démarche de 7,8
humour bas dans le 7-8 humour c'est
aussi de se dire que ce territoire et
qui a été quand même assez riche en
talents notamment humour je vais pas
rappeler tout ce j'ai suivi mais il y en
a un petit nom un petit nombre s'était
déjà belle debbouze y en a beaucoup mais
10 à doumbia arnaud tsamère tous ces
gens sophia aram tous ces gens qui
viennent de ce terroir
font que je me suis dit et c'est pour ça
que virginie est venu me chercher aussi
il ya forcément encore une richesse là
qui n'est pas encore assez exploité pour
moi est donc là il ya une possibilité
une opportunité de pouvoir donner cette
possibilité de venir sur un plateau est
tout et je crois que j'ai hâte de deux
de les voir ce prêt se se jouer là ce
soir là bas demain d'être sur le plateau
et puis débat de s'essayer à cet
exercice pas évident et qui est l'humour
alors dans le déroulé ces jeunes talents
avait jusqu'à la mi octobre pour
candidater vous envoyer leurs vidéos et
ce qu'ils ont été nombreux
alors il ya eu effectivement en plus à
dépasser le cadre même de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines puisque des
gens nous envoient des vélos des vidéos
de tous et et de croyants de marseille
donc ben on voit que ça ça ça ouvre ce
champ là de possibles et le cru est bon
de ce premier essai tu écoutais dos et
de ses premiers crus on en a on en a
retiré quatre ou cinq et puis
moi je pense qu'ils sont bons parce que
ils ont cette envie de partager ceux se
ses traits d'humour qu'ils ont donc les
mais devient cette sélection comment ça
se passe c'est de la préparation donc
une âpre ils ont eu la chance de jeudi
entre guillemets de nous rencontrer
julie et moi est effectivement de nous
présenter ce qu'ils avaient ce qu'ils
voulaient donner à voir de pouvoir
travailler que des professionnels en
face d'eux et de recadrer de de dire
qu'il faut accentuer ici c'est plutôt ça
cet univers-là ce trait d'humour là il
faut le garder
voilà et d'être accompagnées aussi parce
que c'est pas évident en fait c'étaient
des débutants il y avait un peu tous
deux des personnes qui étaient dire des
choses qui m'ont un peu de métier quand
même qu'ils ont déjà fait des plateaux
et qui est utile et celles qui sont en
écriture de leur spectacle entier donc
je vous dis j'ai vraiment hâte de les
voir demain dans ce dans ce cadre du
coup de main alors demain on va avoir
trois 3 3 personnes qui ont déjà du
métier il ya nadia roz il ya laura
demande il ya david azencot ce qu'ils
sont effectivement nos piliers on va
dire qu'ils ont du métier qui sont déjà
en vue qui joue sur paris qui ont leur
spectacle et ensuite on a effectivement
mounir tam'si d'alexandra johanna qui
sont effectivement bas nono rolland qui
sont nos recrues de ce plateau là la
chance qu'on a et comme c'est un partage
avec tes défile c'est c2c de pouvoir
effectivement avoir la possibilité pour
eux d'être présentés de rejouer et de le
faire aussi dans des conditions de
captation qui n'auront pas ailleurs et
ce concept qui l'a amenée à se
renouveler
eh bien oui parce qu'on est comme ça on
fait pas un seul coup ça va ça va être
du bailleur trois temps dans l'année
pour le faire est vraiment chatte et
j'espère que d'ailleurs ce premier là va
donner l'envié à d'autres d'écrire de
présenter donc y aura un nouveau une
nouvelle fois on fera une appel un appel
à un sketch et à ea jeu et voilà les
puits et si bon que ça continue on va
lancer un début c'est une ouverture
je trouve ça intéressant aujourd'hui
parce qu'il n'avait pas c'est aussi de
se dire qu'est ce qu'on fait et c'est
pas forcément amener des talents à saint
quentin
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait des talents de
cinquante ans et ça ça m'intéresse merci
papier d'être pressé sur ce plateau le
plateau 7,8 humeau à retrouver demain
soir à 20h30 au prisme d'elancourt une
soirée qui est malheureusement déjà
victime de son succès il n'y a plus de
place mais elle sera à retrouver en
diffusion sur télé 78 très prochainement
il nous rejoint platonique à l'ennemi
d'eurobonds soir on va parler avec vous
comme chaque lundi de sport
[Musique]
et avant de nous présenter ses résultats
sport du week-end il sera votre invité
dans votre émission le cetud sport un
jeune chrétien champion du monde de
tumbling axel duriez 13 ans a été sacré
à la mi-novembre champion du monde à
saint pétersbourg en russie dans cette
discipline qui consiste à faire un
enchaînement de saut acrobatique sur une
piste une belle performance pour ce
sportif qui pratique le tumbling depuis
six ans seulement la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois l'a récompensé de la
médaille de la ville samedi lors d'une
cérémonie
sa réaction collectées au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude c'est
beaucoup d'honneur même pour mon club ou
pour ma famille pour toutes les
personnes des classes et beaucoup de
verts que j'ai et je les remercie
très clairement les remercie beaucoup de
m'avoir excellent duriez a retrouvé donc
dans l'émission c'est du sport tout à
l'heure sur tv 78 michael pour votre
tour d'horizon des résultats du week-end
on commence par du football direction
maurepas tu peux rien vous cacher un
grégory allaeys mort pas à se rassure en
difficulté dans le championnat de
première division de district depuis le
début de la saison les à mort d'asia ont
réussi à tenir en échec à domicile le
leader marly-le-roi dans un match fermé
ce n'était pas du grand spectacle le
score un triste 0 à 0 on écoute les
réactions à la fin du match
points négatifs on marque quatre buts
point positif on n'en prend pas non plus
après dans le négatif on n'arrive pas
vraiment enchaîner des combinaisons
on n'arrive pas à faire cinq six sept
passes d'affilée donc difficile de se
créer des occasions difficile de de
progresser vers l'avant malgré cette
performance face au leader les mort pas
un restent neuvièmes du championnat six
longueurs du podium au repas tentera de
commencer une série dès ce dimanche 9
décembre les verts recevront le chesnais
de 3e du championnat on espère retrouver
mort pas en haut du classement alors du
basket pour continuer michael une
troisième victoire consécutive pour
l'entente le chesnay versailles dans le
championnat de prénationale les
yvelinois se sont imposés à domicile
contre le maccabi de sarcelles sur le
score de 89 à 80 un match dominé de bout
en bout malgré quelques frayeurs en fin
de match on écoute les réactions en
deuxième mi-temps on est resté un petit
peu sur son nom aux tirs extérieurs
on n'a pas assez varié le jeu ce qui a
fait que sans adresse sarcelles a
commencé à remonter
alors on avait prévenu les joueurs que
ça allait être un match plutôt compliqué
la victoire est au bout c'est le
principal le match était un peu
compliquée et donc on a su être solides
par moments il ya des matches qui sont
pas facile du tout tu préfère avoir des
matches comme ça que les matches faciles
donc ça ça nous permet de travailler à
venir pour continuer sa série de
victoires l'entente le
chesnay-versailles recevra ce samedi 8
décembre paris basket à venir une
rencontre qui comptera pour le début de
la phase retour
bonne dynamique chez les garçons de
l'entente le chesnay versailles est ce
que les résultats sont aussi
satisfaisants pour les filles et ça va
très bien chez les filles également
l'équipe féminine du chesnay versailles
et jouer dans le championnat de
nationale 3 ce week end les yvelinois se
sont imposés 81 à 62 à l'extérieur sur
le terrain de passer une victoire qui
permet aux joueuses de conserver la
première place du classement après 9
journées disputées
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile contre gravenchonnais merci
michael pour ce tour d'horizon vous
retrouve dans un instant pour votre
émission le 7-8 force et la fin de ce
journal belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]